[Music]
Oh
Matt listen we're gonna watch the
daredevil season 3 trailer today you
sure it's such a good idea it's only 30
seconds long like 30 seconds long
we are lawyers I know we are we're
supposed to do this the right way just
we got to do the reaction everyone was
asking for it's going on between you and
Karen I did her in the ass what I didn't
know I'm blind I was in the right case
you haven't heard Marvel's daredevil
season 3 teaser job I think it's like
just a second says 52 seconds terabits
like 30 seconds in a Netflix logo from
25 days we really need to be reminded
where they are that must mean at a real
trailers coming soon but let's face it
everyone's been waiting for daredevil
season 3 trailer I gotta watch this
I just gotta watch it man there knows
the best one of them all just thinking
about it a lot last night
let's just see what they got in store
for us man myself
[Music]
darkness only responds to darkness
I do this
[Music]
I'd rather dies the dough than what I
just Matt oh the gloves Monday oh guy I
remember I feel like nothing to you guys
I'm just gonna watch this bag again I
just gotta do for myself I once believed
that justice could be found in a court
of law justice
it's got the Rosary in hand today you
have bloody rose devil goes to
confession I was fooling myself [ __ ]
obviously responds to darkness
I choose this
[Music]
I'd rather dyes the devil does matter
God you know all those hopes I had for
Matt settling down and becoming a lawyer
aren't you gonna cook I know I just
wanted a lawyer season this like let's
do a lunch of courtroom scenes I want to
see them argue I want this to be the
practice but more common food not this
time guys man this couldn't come at a
better time I haven't seen the Iron Fist
season they dropped over the weekend
I've heard it's amazing yeah I've heard
it's inferred it's basically more okay
daredevil I heard this one is really
inspired by the born-again graphic novel
which I have not read so I actually
purchased it on Amazon yesterday so it
should be in the mail tomorrow got that
part yeah even though I know it's gonna
be very loosely based I wanna I just
want to read it looking at this imagery
first off he's got the original black
suit back eBay oh right old-school and
he's all right so the reason this video
is getting up Leah says you spend a half
hour looking for this just like a flash
it all looks green come on man the
daredevil masked vigilante vigilante
vision on this one right here this
outfit Wow whatever like flash depiction
of it man the nerd community cares about
that [ __ ] he had a costume at the end of
season one he had a different upgrade
throughout season two now is that
nothing it's cost you this was the best
costume of them all this is the bat like
the other costumes are tactical in this
one you're just like it's just like
black pants and a TV you know this is
gonna need to make a bandanna mask
yeah yeah just maximum rough-and-tumble
and he doesn't have I hold so it's like
like severe kind of pointy almost like
beak like like yes Coco Yami and then my
hero academia yeah I think it looks very
imposing and that's the thing is I like
a teaser like this
it's very simple and very tense well
looks like it's going back to a lot of
the door door roots like it never lost
the darkness the whole season takes
place in truth yeah this is the big
confession recap like what it's like
buried or something in this moment
though what we're getting is a good
tease that where his character is at
because he's he's always trying to find
that right line of doing the right thing
there's a lot of lawyer stuff and in
season two the city's been sick and the
cops they can't fix it alone they need
we all need men and women who are
willing to take the fight Michelle says
he's trying to compete here but he's
also trying to abide by the law and
simultaneously it looks like here he's
going full on darkness darkness why
response to darkness he's just embracing
what the devil in Hell's Kitchen means
well in given worse season 2 ended up I
mean I I'm not entirely surprised
because you know I mean with a with a
shattered heart and and all that other
stuff yeah I can imagine he's all hold
no holds barred now you haven't seen the
defenders I can't wait to see it those
he saw season wanted to but he didn't
see the defenders unlike Jessica Jones
which has like no linkage at all to the
defenders this season we'll have to pick
up a little bit from what happens at the
a no defenders I'm gonna watch the iron
fist and then I'm gonna watch this baby
just watchin defenders so now you give
the Matt Murdock storyline but
especially after what happens in the end
of the defenders it will make even more
sense for me for where this is headed
out of here in this season they're gonna
introduce Matt Murdock's mom
get Maggie where she's been all these
years what I've heard from a few people
who got some got a taste for someone
like the first few episode they said
that this season is much much darker
than anything else Netflix has had
officer badass
alright ex super badass and Daredevils
the one that could get away with B&E
darkest yeah I mean this is like some
dude got his head smashed yeah car door
15 min I don't know when this scene
would take place I can't tell if it's
like maybe the third episode or ten
minutes before this he had a new suit
and everything I mean he's just so
messed up that it looks I imagine that
there's a big character loss of where
this moments coming from the fact that
he's all jacked up he's still bleeding
and he seems to be in such a sense of
despair I imagine that a major character
or a character that's been introduced in
the season has just died and he has no
choice but to kind of cross over to the
other side imagine maybe who was
bullseye or we know kingpins coming back
this season to Vanessa
caribou you know part of the fun of Matt
Murdock as a character is is teetering
between the darkness and the light and
personally you know like I always root
for the light side of Matt I'm nervous
actually as to what they're gonna give
us with him this season seem like he is
going to be a challenging probably
antihero certainly you know of course of
course yeah I can't wait for the actual
trailer to drop I'm assuming sometime in
the next few days it will actually come
out to be the best time the month right
here speaking at time of the month
someone's birthday is coming up soon as
a patron of the day right here Joe Bryce
ik Joe Bryce ik is all the way from
Wisconsin yeah get that cheese and he
found us actually from the Schmo down
and when we were talking to messages he
talked about my little roundhouse kick
roll that footage so got a top
[Applause]
the shoutouts about me doing that
I love daredevil Jobriath what he was
telling me in messages is that he runs a
company line of medical oral care was
reading it right here it's basically
what hospital use an intensive care
units to help prevent pneumonia so what
he's doing is getting people a lot of
good and yeah I can't say the words as
of right yellow dollar bill signs I can
make jokes about Karen page doing here
in the you know are gonna be great yeah
sex is gonna be so much dark but Joe
like as we've been talking it's really
cool to know a guy who cares so much
about the lives of other people he has a
passion for being in the medical field
he also has big passion for cinema as
well so Joe thank you so much for being
part of our patreon man and man you're
one hell of a dude I'm happy to know you
and your birthday is coming up
so happy early birthday I don't think
you're a Virgo but I'm gonna say you are
cuz I'm a Virgo
virgos unite everyone's a Virgo everyone
thanks for watching you can check us on
patreon we got full-length TV show
reactions and weekly Q&A plus maybe
we'll do season 3 yeah yeah I think you
guys can subscribe at the reject nation
please click that notification better
get notified every time one of our
videos up love myself
you